[Music]
I know my mom won't remember me to stand
straight right now
mom where's are you mi okay thanks to
Academy for giving me this award first I
want to thank my cast and crew and a big
thanks to my family thank you so much
for hardly supporting and believing in
me and even act in my film my grandma is
the act the others
she's a destroy yourself than this this
is her first time acting in a film I
also want to thank my school University
of Southern California where I started
my trail the last but not the least I
want to thank my mentor Michael who know
a professor Richard Burton and other
faculties for supporting me and I was
not very confident girl before but they
always encouraged me and helped me to
ask me to tell stories from my heart and
after many screenings many people find
me tell me I like your story and I want
to hear what happens next maybe some of
them now choose but I will take the
advantage to become more brave and tell
more story from my two hearts I hope you
can touch more people the whole series
yeah - go - yeah
since father-son summer season episode a
t-shirt
sorry no sir
[Music]